but first ignore the brainwashed zombies
in the streets tonight the written house
trial was carried out in accordance with
the rule of law which itself is rooted
in british common law going back 400
years
the prosecution put on its case
embarrassing itself in the process
then the defense put on its own case
with mr rittenhouse choosing to waive
his fifth amendment rights he took the
stand in his own defense
commentators blathered on on television
about how rittenhouse was a vigilante
and then left-wing pundits they lied
about the underland lying circumstances
that led to the shooting
and of course billionaire celebrities
like lebron james mock the defendant's
emotional testimony
but the jury heard it all
they considered the facts
and deliberated for a few days
the presiding judge kept the proceeding
from going off the rails and in the end
despite threats of violence and
retribution
the jury did its duty
acquittal was the only verdict that made
any sense based on the facts
it wasn't even close
but to the left
the acquittal of written house only
proves what they thought about america
all along that it's a horrible awful
racist place where life is fundamentally
unfair
are we safer after this verdict are we
safe if we let someone like kyle
rittenhouse kill people and then claim
self-defense gun owners with a certain
ideology may feel incentivized now they
are mainstreaming and celebrating
political violence a white boy deputized
himself this is about making sure that
white supremacy maintains its cover to
terrorize and intimidate the rest of us
these are all poisonous lies they're
untrue
and they're words that demoralize young
people and encourage millions people to
just simply give up on america
after all why work hard to play by the
rules to get ahead in a disgusting
racist nation who would do that
these are bitter angry people who hate
america and who are constantly looking
for confirmation of their anti-american
views
now president biden could have come down
the crazies today all day long after
this verdict came out but instead
he chose the coward's path
releasing a statement saying he agrees
with those who are angry and concerned
about the verdict but that we must
acknowledge that the jury has spoken
now even though he goes on and urges
people to protest peacefully his message
the way it's worded is corrosive and
counterproductive the fact is
democrats gave their tacit approval to
all the damage that was inflicted on
american cities after george floyd
they made excuses for criminality and
they celebrated the passion of young
people in the streets
maybe white house chief of staff ron
klain thinks racial discontent is the
only hope of stopping the red wave next
november i have no idea but none of it
will work
americans are supposed to believe that
because what written house was acquitted
wisconsin by the way a state that
biden won is so the wisconsin now is
racist
with racist jurors and racist judges
odd
no wonder democrats are poised to get
wiped out next year
in the end facts do matter
whether we're talking about the economy
gas prices
or a trial where a then 17 year old acts
in self-defense against an angry mob hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else